ci sono delle domande che ti cambiano la
vita che non si sa bene come e perché
vengono alla luce e dopo quel momento
quella piccola scintilla di pensiero
niente è più come prima E anch'io ho la
mia domanda il problema però è che non
ho ancora trovato la risposta ed è una
ricerca che dura da tanti anni ed è
anche il motivo che mi ha portato qui
stasera al centro di questo bollino
rosso qual è la mia domanda ma in realtà
È anche semplice Che cos'è la musica Beh
Sembra semplice in realtà non lo è
affatto perché ho scoperto che più entro
in profondità più Cerco delle risposte
più trovo un universo di risposte tutte
diverse e tutte giuste però c'è sempre
un momento una scintilla che illumina il
buio e fa nascere un'idea un pensiero
una visione
e quindi questa sera ve lo voglio
raccontare vi voglio raccontare questa
storia partendo proprio dall'inizio di
tutto e c'è un momento che è molto
importante per tutti noi per l'umanità
per il mondo per l'universo intero il
momento in cui tutto è nato il big bang
ve lo dicevo è che partivo dall'inizio
questa sera e il big bang poi ha un nome
così musicale non so se ci avete mai
fatto caso Ed è proprio il momento in
cui dal buio si passa la luce dal nulla
si passa al tutto dal silenzio si passa
ad un Big Bang che ha creato l'universo
e quindi troviamo la luce e la musica
all'inizio di tutto Però forse è solo
una coincidenza legata a questo nome che
la scienza ha dato al Big Bang io non
credo molto alle coincidenze però mi
incuriosiscono molto e più torniamo
indietro nel nostro passato e ritroviamo
la storia dell'umanità più scopriamo
quanto antichi siano i legami che
uniscono il mondo della musica alla
Magia della luce Infatti tutte le volte
che la nascita del mondo è descritta con
sufficiente precisione nel momento
decisivo dell'azione interviene Un suono
una fonte acustica un suono nato nel
vuoto che fa vibrare il nulla e crea il
tutto ogni volta che un Dio decide di
creare la vita lo fa attraverso una
fonte acustica un suono
tuona ride grida parla canta suono uno
strumento la nascita del mondo è sempre
una fonte acustica questo perché nelle
antiche civiltà la musica Il canto
avevano una forte Valenza Mistica ed
erano strettamente collegate con i miti
della creazione e con i miti della luce
infatti in sanscrito suono si dice svara
e luce si dice svar e secondo un'antica
cosmogonia indiana che una tra le più
affascinanti di tutte si racconta che il
mondo è nato da una graduale
materializzazione di un suono
primordiale e questi ritmi sonori sono
diventati poi luce una luce sonora La
prima impalpabile poi sempre più
compatta finché ha creato la materia ed
ecco quindi perché la musica è qualcosa
che per quello per quella religione ci
mette sempre in collegamento il cielo
con la terra no e lì il musicista viene
definito come colui che ha la luce
dentro di sé questo perché tra tutti gli
esseri mortali è colui che è ancora
molta musica No dentro il suo animo
dentro il suo spirito e quindi lo
collega e lo avvicina agli dei Forse
però questa è una cultura molto
affascinante come vi dicevo Ma un po'
diversa lontana dalla nostra Allora
torniamo nel nostro Occidente e
cominciamo a leggere le prime righe del
libro della Bibbia della Genesi no e lì
troviamo la famosissima frase E Dio
disse sia luce e luce fu anche Dio nella
Bibbia crea attraverso un suono
attraverso il suono della parola
attraverso il suono della parola luce
Dio crea la luce è una fusione perfetta
No tra questi due elementi e poi lo
sappiamo di ho sempre con il suono della
parola creerà poi tutto il resto del
mondo questo Forse ancora una visione un
po' astratta no Allora mi avvicino nella
storia e vado nella culla della nostra
civiltà nell'antica Grecia e tra le
tante cose che potrei citare ne dico
solo una il mito del dio Apollo il dio
del sole il Dio della luce e anche il
dio della musica
Vabbè stasera ho scomodato sto
scomodando un po' di personalità
importanti eh beh allora a questo punto
ho fatto 30 faccio 31 e chiamo in causa
anche lui sommo poeta Dante e la sua
Divina Commedia inferno Purgatorio
Paradiso un viaggio non solo verso la
luce ma anche un viaggio verso la musica
Dante Infatti descrive il paradiso come
un luogo di luce e di suoni talmente
forti accecanti che ne rimane annientato
e nel Paradiso Dante arriva al cospetto
di Dio dell'empire o nell'empire no di
Dio di tutto dell'assoluto e quando è lì
come lo descrive lo descrive come
un'emanazione di luce di suoni una luce
talmente forte talmente accecante che lo
abbaglia e non vede più nulla e noi lo
sappiamo che succede così No quando
abbiamo una luce fortissima che ci punta
contro non vediamo più niente Sembra
quasi un paradosso e insieme a questa
luce fortissima una musica bellissima
una musica Cele generale la musica delle
sfere celesti la musica delle eterne
rote una musica che anche il sommo poeta
fa fatica a descrivere Infatti dice
Dante io non la intendo non la capisco e
perché Perché Dante è lì come un essere
umano in carne e ossa no non è uno
spirito puro Purificato che ha raggiunto
il Paradiso e quindi Dante come essere
umano come essere imperfetto non riesce
a concepire a capire la musica e quindi
nel paradiso la musica arriva a
trascendere il significato intellettuale
e diventa un mezzo per esprimere il
Mistero dell'amore eterno dell'amore
assoluto
queste possono essere lette come delle
belle storie una bella storia scritta da
un grande poeta i miti e le religioni si
tramandano da secoli ci possiamo credere
o meno e quindi allora la musica che
cos'è nella nostra realtà fisica nella
realtà che cos'è La scienza ci dice che
la musica è un fenomeno fisico acustico
nato dalla vibrazione di un corpo
elastico chiaro preciso ma molto meno
poetico chiaramente No La musica è
formata da onde sonore di cui noi oggi
possiamo nel dettaglio conoscere tutto
altezza timbro durata chiaro però questa
è una risposta che non so a voi ma a me
non soddisfa appieno perché la musica Ok
è questo ma non può essere solo questo
perché è qualcosa che ci fa emozionare
che ci fa cantare che ci fa ballare a
volte che ci fa anche piangere La musica
è qualcosa a cui non so voi ma io non
riuscirai mai a fare a meno
diventare un mondo senza musica io non
riesco nemmeno proprio a pensarci questo
perché la musica mi ha affascinato da
sempre fin dai miei primi giri intorno
al sole e ancora una volta la musica e
la luce sono molto uniti no anche nel
nostro presente non solo nei racconti
delle mitologia ancestrali perché la
musica e la luce fanno parte delle
nostre giornate ci sono sono ovunque
attorno a noi eppure non le possiamo
toccare No non le possiamo afferrare
però
delle diamo Quasi come per scontate no e
la musica e la luce oggi basta un click
e arrivano subito dove come e quando
vogliamo però la musica deve avere
qualcosa di speciale Perché alle volte
bastano quelle poche note di una canzone
di quella canzone per emozionarci
facciamo pazzie per andare ad un
concerto spendiamo soldi in dischi in
vinili io personalmente molto oppure
anche
posizioniamo No con una canzone con una
musica ascoltiamo Salviamo ore e ore di
playlist infinite nei nostri telefoni ma
perché ma che cos'è la musica Insomma io
a un certo punto lo volevo capire lo
dovevo capire e questo è stato il mio
big bang una scintilla che ha acceso una
miccia E ha scatenato in me
un'esplosione che mi ha portato a
studiare musica e a cercare le mie
risposte
Che cos'è la musica una delle mie
risposte preferite è che la musica è 42
No non sto dando i numeri è tranquilli
questa è la risposta alla domanda
fondamentale sulla vita l'universo e
tutto quanto scritta nel libro Guida
galattica per autostoppisti di Douglas
Adams chiaramente è una risposta
surreale perché una risposta in realtà
ma questa domanda non si può avere
questa chiaramente è la risposta
continuava il libro ad essere sinceri
penso che il problema sia che voi non
abbiate mai saputo veramente Qual è la
domanda
e qui c'è un punto interessante Infatti
a pensarci bene non esiste nemmeno una
musica sola esistono tantissime musiche
le musiche di tutte le culture diverse
dalla nostra perché noi siamo abituati a
pensare che esiste il nostro Occidente
la nostra musica con tutti i sottogeneri
la nostra storia della musica con i
nostri importanti musicisti ma in realtà
ci sono tantissime musiche le musiche di
tutte le culture diverse dalla nostra
che si sono succedute nei secoli Ma
quindi allora che cos'è la musica perché
è qualcosa di così difficile da definire
sebbene la conosciamo tutti e tutte le
culture No la conoscono e ne hanno
creata perché è capace di suscitare
emozioni e così profonde e potenti
questo perché la musica ha tanti
superpoteri e uno dei più potenti è la
capacità di elevare il livello della
nostra vita emotiva e la musica ci
riesce perché noi la nostra mente
associa alla musica al suono un
significato per cui trascende e va al di
là del puro suono infatti in realtà la
musica non è fondamentale per la vita
dell'uomo non è restare senza musica non
è come restare senza sonno no che può
causare un danno fisico oppure restare
senza cibo o senza acqua si può
sopravvivere senza la musica dicono io
personalmente non so se ci riuscirei
Però dicono che anch'io senza C senza
musica potrai sopravvivere Questo
sarebbe un esperimento interessante che
però dico subito che non ho nessuna
intenzione di fare ma perché anch'io
potrei sopravvivere senza musica Perché
la musica non è importante per il
singolo La musica è importante per la
specie umana sapete che non esistono
culture senza musica Questo è molto
interessante tutte le civiltà sempre ed
sempre hanno creato una qualche forma di
linguaggio musicale magari non hanno
sviluppato un linguaggio scritto non
sono arrivati a quel punto
dell'evoluzione Ma hanno creato un
linguaggio musicale tutte le civiltà
sempre noi siamo esseri musicali non
meno che linguistici quindi è molto
importante ricordare che i nostri
istinti per la musica sono radicati
nell'infanzia dell'umanità le forme
musicali che erano disponibili agli
uomini primitivi la voce e il corpo
magari percuotendo no il proprio corpo
esercitano ancora oggi un influenza
primaria inevitabile le canzoni e poi le
parole organizzate ritmicamente sono
state sono ancora oggi il mezzo primario
di comunicazione tra le culture non
alfabetizzate la musica il suono quindi
ci riconnette la nostra natura
primordiale la musica ci riconnette alla
nostra natura essenziale
l'evoluzione però non ci ha aiutato a
prendere consapevolezza di questo
l'abbiamo un po' dimenticato e oggi la
musica come dicevo prima come con la
luce è una presenza naturale nelle
nostre giornate la diamo per scontata
c'è non ci facciamo neanche troppo caso
e come la luce ovunque No basta un click
dicevamo Prima torna subito la musica
Oggi è un bene di consumo non ci fa
neanche più strano pensarla così e anche
parlare di inquinamento musicale è
qualcosa che non è certo una novità in
realtà poi lo sappiamo che la musica è
importante che la musica è cultura che
alcune canzoni dovrebbero magari essere
anche spiegate a scuola però poi
rimangono sempre solo canzonette non le
prendiamo mai troppo sul serio ecco che
Allora dovrebbe cambiare il modo in cui
noi ci approcciamo alla musica cercando
di conoscere per il suo valore per la
sua essenza culturale la musica non
dovrebbe essere solo lungodimento
estetico un momento di intrattenimento
il significato della musica anche in ciò
che noi facciamo con la musica come la
ascoltiamo e perché studiare musica non
è soltanto imparare la storia di la
biografia di un artista sapere la storia
di un'opera imparare a suonare uno
strumento conoscere ogni battuta di una
partitura anche questo ma non solo
perché la musica è la storia
dell'umanità e la storia dell'uomo
raccontata secondo i suoi atti sonori è
la storia degli uomini che hanno fatto
parlato e tramandato la musica chi come
cosa perché quando se noi concepiamo la
musica così riusciamo a capire avere una
chiave di lettura in più per capire per
comprendere per leggere il nostro
passato capire chi eravamo chi siamo
stati le nostre evoluzioni rivoluzioni
come è cambiata la cultura la società
per capire meglio il nostro presente chi
siamo e anche per avere una visione sul
futuro
Dove stiamo andando la musica si
specchia nella società e nella cultura
La musica è cultura La musica è arte la
musica però è anche scienza matematica e
fisica La musica è letteratura e poesia
È la musica è sociologia antropologia
religione La musica è evoluzione
rivoluzione scoperta La musica è un
universo in continua espansione
Che cos'è la musica Allora alla fine io
ho capito che non è tanto importante
trovare questa la risposta a questa
domanda L'importante è porsi La domanda
è una piccola scintilla che può
accendere una miccia e scatenare un Big
Bang che crea un infinito di mondi che
si può avere la possibilità di conoscere
però bisogna avere la curiosità e la
voglia di ascoltare di osservare e di
imparare
La musica è ovunque presenta impalpabile
accecante Non ne possiamo fare a meno
però non dobbiamo dimenticare che la
musica come la luce non esisterebbe
senza al buio per apprezzare la luce
dobbiamo conoscere il buio è un gioco di
delicati equilibri no come quella
piccola pausa che separa una parola
dall'altra una frase dall'altra e dalla
possibilità di comprendere il senso di
un discorso che assieme Altrimenti
sarebbe solo un fluire indefinito no di
suoni come nella musica c'è la pausa che
distanzia una nota dall'altra senza il
silenzio non ci sarebbe né parola e
nemmeno la musica
quindi e se nella nostra realtà
fenomenica La musica è un'increspatura
in un silenzio altrimenti piatto e vuoto
siamo noi uomini con la nostra
percezione e con la nostra sensibilità
che abbiamo la possibilità di
trasformare quel piccolo spazio tra
suono e silenzio
[Applauso]